since tobey maguire first on the red and
blue Spidey suit back in 2002 we've had
five film outings three green Goblin's
to Peter Parker's and a partridge in a
oh wait with the wall-crawler making a
cameo appearance in the latest trailer
for Captain America Civil War it's time
now for Tom Holland to take up the
spider mantle I'm Simon and here's your
friendly neighborhood news updates
Marvel's new spider-man movie has been
titled spider-man homecoming and
alongside the lead role it now looks
like we may know who's playing the
villain according to Deadline batman
actor Michael Keaton is reportedly in
talks to play a villain in the movie the
film is a co-production between Sounion
marvel and both studios have declined to
comment on deadlines information keaton
playing a role in homecoming would mark
his return to comic book movies his last
appearance was in batman returns as the
Caped Crusader himself we've seen the
likes of electro Doctor Octopus Sandman
and other bodies in previous Spidey
films but the villain Keaton will play
is unconfirmed at this moment which bad
guys would you like to see on screen are
you craving for Craven hungry for hydro
man or are you longing for more lizard
let me know in the comments below or
find me on Twitter I'm at the j cannot
thanks for watching and for all your
entertainment news keep it gamespot's